Olá pessoal hoje vamos falar sobre um
tema que todo mundo adora e muitos
utilizam que é a água com limão eu
indico muito paraos meus pacientes e ao
mesmo tempo percebo que ainda tem muitas
dúvidas sobre esse assunto por isso eu
quero esclarecer alguns erros comuns e
cuidados ao tomar a água com limão quem
pode quem não pode e quem deve prestar
atenção e ter cuidado especialmente se
você está usando água com limão todos os
dias é bem importante você saber o que
que eu vou explicar de uma maneira bem
simples e rápida eu não vou focar nos
benefícios da água com limão hoje porque
eu já fiz vários vídeos sobre isso
Inclusive eu tenho um vídeo onde eu falo
bastante sobre os seus benefícios que eu
vou deixar aqui na descrição não deixa
de conferir Ok então vamos para o erro
número um achar que todo mundo vai se
dar bem tomando água com limão isso tem
relação Direta com a digestão e temos
algumas versões e opiniões
diversas díspares diferentes sobre isso
alguns especialistas dizem que não se
deve consumir água com limão antes de
comer porque embora o ácido cítrico
presente no limão seja um ácido quando
ele entra no corpo ele é queimado e se
transforma em uma substância alcalina E
com isso estamos basicamente
alcalinizando o nosso ácido clorídrico o
que não seria nada bom porque isso vai
prejudicar a nossa digestão então eles
indicam consumir água com limão pelo
menos meia hora a 1 hora antes de comer
qualquer coisa mas temos uma outra visão
que é a prevalente de que o primeiro
contato do limão com o estômago ele está
no ambiente áo já que a própria água com
limão é asa possui um PH próximo ao
ácido gástrico isso vai na realidade
estimular a produção de ácido clorídrico
e não Ibi ficou confuso bom para você
entender melhor é importante saber que
para uma boa digestão precisamos ter uma
quantidade adequadas de ácido clorídrico
no estômago esse Ácido é essencial pro
esvaziamento gástrico de forma adequada
e paraa produção de enzimas digestivas
que ajudam na assimilação de nutrientes
que é o caso de proteínas vitaminas e
minerais no entanto podemos ter duas
condições excesso de ácido ou falta de
ácido no estômago
e os sintomas de ambas as condições são
bem parecidos se você tem excesso de
ácido conhecido como hipercloridria você
pode experimentar sintomas como aia
arroto gastrite gases distensão
abdominal por outro lado a falta de
ácido a hipocloridria que é mais comum
bem mais comum hoje em dia pode causar
sintomas bem semelhantes algumas pessoas
relatam que ao tomar água com limão os
seus sintomas de gastrite desaparecem e
elas se sentem muito melhor outras no
entanto dizem que a água com limão acaba
piorando seus sintomas acaba causando
queimação dor levando essas pessoas a
desistir de utilizar então se você tem
uma gastrite causado por excesso de Aço
no estômago tomar água com limão pode
estimular ainda mais a produção do ácido
clorídrico e isso vai exacerbar vai
piorar os sintomas porém se a sua
gastrite é causado por falta de ácido a
água com limão pode ajudar a melhorar os
sintomas Porque o limão vai estimular a
produção de ácido clorídrico que é o
ácido necessário para a digestão
saudável e claro tem aquelas pessoas que
estão com o estômago saudável e não vão
sentir nada nem bom nem
ruim apenas colher os benefícios Gerais
das vitaminas e minerais que o limão
possui Então pessoal vejam que isso
depende muito de cada um da
individualidade Ok eu quero que vocês
deixem aqui nos comentários qual que foi
a experiência que vocês tiveram com á
com limão em relação à digestão melhorou
piorou queimou não queimou vocês
sentiram melhora ou pior ao tomar é
importante entender isso porque algumas
pessoas podem ter sintomas negativos en
contra outras pessoas vão sentir
melhoras para aqueles que que sofrem de
hiperacidez no estômago é provável que a
mucosa desse órgão esteja danificada e
desprotegida muitas vezes essas pessoas
podem ter uma gastrite mais intensa mais
Severa devido a excesso de ácido ou até
mesmo uma esofagite de refluxo e úlceras
nesse órgão esôfago então entenda que se
você começar a tomar água com limão e
sentir desconforto pior a situação tiver
dor queimação é importante parar de
tomar imediatamente e procurar um médico
para diagnóstico se descobrir que você
tem uma dessas condições Você precisará
tratar a inflamação primeiro o que você
vai fazer por exemplo se tiver uma
gastrite Severa é esperar que toda a
inflamação passe e seguir o tratamento
recomendado pelo seu médico trate a
inflamação até que você sinta que está
curado ou curada e sua fisiologia
estomacal esteja no normalizada
novamente Isso inclui ter níveis normais
de ácio no estômago e produção adequada
de muco para proteger a parede gástrica
só depois disso você pode começar a
introduzir o limão
novamente passo a passo aos poucos para
ver como é que você se sente e para usar
o limão corretamente especialmente se
você nunca tomou não tem experiência com
água com limão comece devagarzinho vai
aos poucos esprema um pouquinho de limão
na água veja como é que você se sente se
tudo estiver bem no dia seguinte esprema
meio limão em um copo de água que pode
ser de 250 A 350 ml e veja como é que
você se sente o ideal é consumir pelo
menos um limão por dia mas se você se
sente bem com meio limão exprimido em um
copo de água Isso já é ótimo lembre-se
de começar devagar e aumentar a
quantidade gradualmente com conforme o
seu corpo se adaptar para as pessoas que
sofrem de falta de ácido no estômago o
limão vai ser um auxiliar muito
interessante na digestão Então essas
pessoas podem se beneficiar bastante do
consumo desse elemento do Limão isso vai
ajudar na digestão e você pode sentir
uma melhora na gastrite que
provavelmente vai ser uma gastrite
atrófica no refluxo E na saúde
digestória de forma geral uma questão
interessante a comentar que também
depende de cada pessoa é que você pode
tomar á com limão um pouco antes das
refeições ou até mesmo utilizar o limão
durante a refeição mas sempre com
moderação nunca em excesso tem pessoas
que se sentem bem tomando água com limão
no horário noturno por exemplo aquelas
que TM refluxo noturno muito comum
quando você tem uma baixa produção de
acio no estômago o esfinter a válvula
esofágica inferior é a aquela estrutura
que fecha e abre no estômago para evitar
o refluxo ela pode ficar aberta pelo
fato de ter pouco ácio nesses casos
tomar água com limão antes de dormir
pode ajudar a fechar melhor esse
esfínter essa válvula assim ao se deitar
o conteúdo gástrico não vai voltar pro
esôfago não vai subir evitando sintomas
de refluxo e tosse noturna no entanto se
o seu caso for de excesso de ácio no
estômago e você utilizar o limão à noite
pode acabar piorando intensificando os
sintomas de refluxo então é muito
individual cada pessoa reage de uma
forma diferente eu me lembro de uma
paciente que tinha uma tosse terrível à
noite
descartando problemas pulmonares através
de exames e foi diagnosticada com
refluxo ela deitava e o conteúdo
gástrico subia causando tosse malestar
ao analisar sua rotina percebi que ela
estava utilizando o limão à noite
espremendo meio limão com magnésio antes
de dormir no caso dela que tinha excesso
de ácido no estômago é a minoria mais
existe o limão à noite não fez bem e
piorou intensificou os sintomas então é
essencial que você preste muito atenção
no seu corpo como seu corpo reage ao
consumo de limão o erro número dois é um
erro simples muitas pessoas acham que ao
espremer meio limão na água e tomar já
estão super cheias de vitamina C
infelizmente não é bem assim o limão é
sim uma fonte de vitamina C mas não é
das melhores que tem na natureza apesar
de ser bem propagado essa infamação que
tem vitamina C ele possui uma quantidade
apenas razoável mas não grandes
quantidades não suficiente para suprir
suas necessidades di áreas de vitamina C
apenas com meio limão espremido na água
então o nosso corpo não fabrica vitamina
C é essencial para nossa saúde e
precisamos obtê-la através de alimentos
apenas meio limão exprimido ainda não é
suficiente para garantir a quantidade
necessária de vitamina C que você vai
que eu vou precisar diariamente então
Além disso se você utilizar o limão em
água quente ou chá a vitamina C que é
sensível ao calor se degrada facilmente
reduzindo ainda mais seus benefícios
então se você gosta de tomar água com
limão morna o ideal é não ferver a água
tem gente que ferve a água até borbulhar
e depois espreme o limão mas isso não é
adequado faça ao contrário ferva água
coloque no seu copo e deixe esfriar até
ficar morna ou temperatura ambiente Aí
sim esprema o limão e beba dessa forma
você preserva melhor a vitamina C mas
lembre-se você precisa complementar a
sua alimentação com outras fontes dessa
vitamina com como acerola kiwii vegetais
verdes escuros e o erro número três é um
erro bastante comum as pessoas que
acabam tomando água com limão esquecem
que o PH do suco do limão é bastante
ácido variando de 2is a três semelhante
ao próprio ácido estômago clorídrico
então Expor os dentes de forma direta e
diária a essa acidez pode danificar o
esmalte então para proteger os seus
dentes é importante tomar alguns
cuidados primeiro Vamos então tomar
esses cuidados primeiro consuma a água
com limão de preferência utilizando o
canudo para evitar que esse suco ácido
entra em contato direto com os dentes
Além disso sempre dilua o suco de limão
em um copo de água para reduzir a
concentração de ácido Depois de beber a
água com limão o ideal é você enxaguar a
sua boca com água pura não com pasta de
dente pois escovar os dentes
imediatamente após consumir algo ácido
pode PI ainda mais o desgaste desse
esmalte
dentário espere pelo menos 30 minutos
antes de escovar os dentes isso permite
que a saliva normalize o PH da boca
ajudando a proteger o esmalte dos dentes
[Música]
comp obrigado por asstir participar
deixe nos comentários as suas
experiências e dúvidas e também se você
gostou ou não gostou coloque o seu like
ou deslike e se inscreva no
canal Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração e
você é o quê você é fera meu amigo ou
minha amiga